cool are you my name is Ellen Andra I
come from a world unknown to you a world
called Shia hey youtubers it's Charlie
so huge news it sounds like Jessica
Chastain is going to be playing lilandra
in Fox's x-men Dark Phoenix movie that
will be dropping next year they get
ready to film later this year I'll be
doing a bunch more x-men videos because
there's so much Deadpool and all this
stuff happening so be sure to subscribe
to get everything
but if they land her it would be a huge
get for them now I know you have a lot
of thoughts about who you like Jessica
Chastain to play in a comic book movie
there's a lot of people that would love
to see her in the DC Universe playing
somebody like Catwoman or poison ivy and
she is an amazing actress which is
really where I feel like comic book
movies are getting so much better is
because they have a really amazing
female villains Cate Blanchet playing
hella in thor ragnarok is like the
watershed moment like oh my god we can
actually get really amazing actresses
and they don't all have to be heroes the
bonus of the x-men universe though is
that I feel like even though there's a
bunch of really cool female characters
at all the studios in the Marvel
Universe cool female characters are in
the x-men universe like if Marvel had
rights to all those Fox characters
guaranteed you would have seen that
x-men movie then you would have seen one
of those female x-men characters joined
the Avengers instead of Black Widow
they've confirmed that James McAvoy
Michael Fassbender and Jennifer Lawrence
are coming back so you have your old
x-men characters Professor X is really
the important part of that equation you
could do Dark Phoenix without Magneto
and mystique if you had to but what
they're calling it is teen spirit that's
the working title of the film so
surprise surprise the movie takes place
in the early 90s so think of it as being
like smells like teen spirit so they'll
be a little bit of that energy to it the
teen aspect being brought by that
original x-men class so you have young
Cyclops young Jean Grey that are a
little bit older than they were during
x-men apocalypse you know though they
haven't confirmed what the exact story
is going to be because if you remember
the 90s animated series they basically
did about I think was six or seven
episodes of that entire saga they
adapted it pretty faithfully I mean they
had to slim it down a little bit
because you have a lot of big space
empires and intergalactic politics with
the Creed the Badoon things that Marvel
have that Fox doesn't have access to so
I would expect a few changes but the
basic plot is that Jean Grey goes into
outer space is possessed by the Phoenix
force the Hellfire Club tries to
manipulate her while separately lilandra
contacts Charles Xavier and is on the
run because her sister and her brother
separately are trying to steal the Shiar
throne from her using them a can crystal
the animated series does a great job of
slimming that story down I'll do a
longer video on this but this is
actually a really good preview for it
why have you come yeah child Acadia let
me show you the emperor of the shi'ar I
served my brother loyally and so I
learned that she sought to control the
greatest power in the universe the
ancient crystal of immigrants
immeasurably powerful my brother hopes
to harness the crystal power to use it
as the weapon
my brother is mad it is written that if
the crystal is breached both of our
galaxies can be at real
Christel funny my brother I violated at
ancient thanks you're wearing the most
sacred temple of Seaford though the
m'kraan crystal
[Music]
I escaped aboard a star cruiser my
Brotherhood CD with the warships of the
Imperial fleet they attempted to destroy
me and my ship to get the crystal I
managed to reach shorten the can will
follow me here in time that is why you
must help me the comic book story took
about twelve issues to tell the story so
it took place over a really long period
of time that's how complicated it got
but you basically have the Shiar empire
trying to get it together you get
into the mythology of the Phoenix force
the Shiar gods which they actually just
used in the Thor comics I'll talk about
them later too because their gods are
total and they're sort of like
the brother and sister of the Phoenix
force so you have this big Shiar coup
that's going on the x-men have to help
out with that the Merkin crystal gets
cracked so Jean Grey has to help fix it
using the Phoenix force then she goes
away and sort of suppresses it but the
Dark Phoenix eventually takes over she
winds up destroying an entire galaxy so
that she our empires after her they want
to kill her the x-men try to defend her
in lilandra comes up with this measure
of last resort to stop the Dark Phoenix
by destroying another entire galaxy so
because Jean Grey has already caused the
deaths of billions of people she doesn't
want that to happen again so she
sacrifices herself and that's when she
dies in the comics it was a very
controversial storyline in the Marvel
offices when they first wrote it and
then when they killed her off you know
obviously fans went crazy is a bit of an
oversimplification of a really huge
comic book story I'll do a much longer
video on it at some point when we learn
more about the actual movie story
because it'll be different from the
comics but if you have the episodes
available its season 3 of x-men the
animated series it's pretty much like a
giant block of episodes in the middle of
that season the only thing they've
confirmed now is it pretty much all the
x-men are coming back from the previous
movie vilandra will be the main
antagonist even though technically she's
not an antagonist and that means that
you'll get into the Shiar Empire but
because it's only a two-hour movie you
can't do this entire story in two hours
so clearly this is going to be setting
up whatever the next movie after it's
going to be but depending on what the
box office is like and how much money
I think that'll alter their plans a
little bit but I think it's really good
that they're pushing into galactic
territory the Shiar empire that could be
their guardians of the galaxy they have
the starjammers so it just opens a lot
of galactic doors at the Fox x-men
universe because you have deadpool
blowing up
you have x-force coming out of that you
have new mutants you have all this
earth-based stuff but there's all these
space-based characters that they have
access to that they haven't tried yet so
let me know in the comments what do you
guys think about all this what do you
think about Jessica Chastain playing one
of the biggest galactic characters in
the Marvel Universe it'll be at Fox but
maybe once they get all this going maybe
they can arrange with Marvel for a big
crossover avenger style movie where you
put the x-men and the Avengers together
in a war of King situation where you
have a big Galactic conflict where they
get to cross over so you have Shiar
Empire stuff happening you have
guardians of the galaxy you don't even
have to involve the earth-based
characters you could just do a Guardians
crossover with the Shiar down the road
but what will happen next is is they
just confirmed that Danny Elfman is
going to be doing the score for Justice
League so I'll do a video for that
remember he did the score for the flash
TV show Batman the 1989 movie which they
also used for the animated series and
the iconic spider-man theme from the
Tobey Maguire films so congratulations
to the latest giveaway winner Fredrik
cotton please private message me so I
can get your contact details while you
wait for everything you can click here
to learn all about infinity war hulk
black panther crossover and you can
click here for brand new flash thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome i'll see you guys tonight
you